ich war mein leben lang und sportlich
zum ersten mal über einen ganzen
kilometer am stück gelaufen bin ich erst
mit 16 oder so und das heißt natürlich
auch dass ich in der schule beim
ausdauerlauf die ein oder andere fünf
oder sechs kassiert hat auf meinem weg
zum erwachsenenalter abgesehen von zwei
monaten fußballtraining als ich acht
jahre alt war hat sich mit ausdauersport
eigentlich nie was am hut
kleiner spass auf dem bild war ich gar
nicht acht sondern schon 16 wartet das
macht es ja noch peinlicher egal ganz
schnell weiter mit dem video in diesem
video möchte ich jetzt aber herausfinden
ob man mit nur einem monat training es
schaffen kann zehn kilometer am stück
durch zu laufen und natürlich auch wie
das training meine laufgeschwindigkeit
verändert und was dabei mit meinem
körper passiert dieses video wird
unterstützt von jim clark die mich wie
schon beim kraftsport setzte experiment
für dieses video wieder mit dem
perfekten sport kamera ausgestattet
haben den link dazu findet ihr in der
video beschreibung wie weit kann ich
laufen als absolut
ich hab mit racking up am start und
damit
[Musik]
da hat man gesehen
ich merke schon langsam dass
seitenstechen klickt ich hab noch nicht
mal ein kilometer
wieso ist es die so steil
ich bin echt hart erkämpfen
ich bin jetzt gerade bei 2,25
und ich muss sagen die 2,5 mache jedoch
vollkommen zahlungs wertung ich habe
1,61 meilen geschafft aber ich dem auf
gebäude ganz unmöglich zerstören
spannender grund also ich habe sagen
minuten gerannt das ist eine preis und 7
minuten und 40 sekunden nicht mehr
machen aber geht also jetzt geht es
wieder ich war ein bisschen ko aber
jetzt nach fünf minuten pause kündigt
weiteren ja mach ich aber nicht
wirklich krass war dann aber eigentlich
das was sie schon am zweiten tag
geschafft habe einen trainingseffekt
kann in der kurzen zeit noch nicht
wirklich eingetreten sein
22.50 beste zeit zum gehen auf jeden
fall jetzt erstmal im finsteren wald tag
ich habe jetzt 4,3 kilometer geschafft
in 30 minuten findet man noch mit dem
werk hessen überall wo jeder für sein
alter noch gar nicht so fertig zu machen
und dieses mal war die strecke sondern
auch schwierige heute tatsächlich
gekommen
für sohn 8 lauf war das schon eine
ansage und obwohl ich fast doppelt so
weit geschockt bin war ich
durchschnittlich auch noch ein gutes
stück schneller 31 minuten bin ich also
ein stück rand ich würde aber sagen dass
es einfach nur die willenskraft deutlich
höher war als im vortrag weil damit habe
ich mein ziel von zehn kilometern zu 43
prozent erreicht und es hat gerade das
mal angefangen aber meine energie war da
nach natürlich kommt am ende deshalb
auch kein wunder ist dass ich dann an
tage drei obwohl ich wieder eine
bestzeit geschafft hat nur 2,2 kilometer
geschafft hat bevor mein körper komplett
schlapp gemacht hat immerhin sehe ich
hier am ende noch halbwegs aus wie ein
mensch im gegensatz zum vortag ich mein
was ist das hier an der uhrzeit sieht
man aber auch dass es da nur zehn
stunden zeitunterschied gehabt wodurch
ist natürlich kein wunder ist dass da
die performance gelitten hat aber bisher
hab ich mich jeden tag fleißig ins zeug
gelegt ja und dann kam erstmal der
gewohnheit impftermine relativ
kurzfristig am vierten tag bekommen
haben und da soll man sich ja eigentlich
schon deswegen nicht an zwei tagen pause
gemacht habe aber umso mehr gas gegeben
habe ich dann tags hier bin ich einmal
quer durch den kölner grüngürtel
geflitzt 2,4 kilometer hin und dann auch
wieder zurück wo ich dann hier sogar
noch mal eine ehrenrunde gedreht habe
damit ich die fünf kilometer hörte
knackte zum ersten mal in meinem leben
35 minuten am stück bin ich gerannt
am anfang richtig flott dann gab es hier
einen durchhänger aber in der letzten
hälfte habe ich noch mal richtig gas
gegeben
jeden tag laufen zu gehen ist zwar
bestimmt nicht das schlauste wie ich
später auch herausfinden werde aber ich
hatte es mir eigentlich schon
vorgenommen und so gehe ich auch am tag
sieben direkt wieder laufen und
zumindest hier habe ich damit sogar
erfolg und kann die distanz erneut
steigern von 5,2 auf 5,5 kilometer und
diesmal sogar mit einer absoluten
bestzeit von 6 minuten 17 da ich hier
zwar am anfang wieder schneller danach
jedoch sehr konstant liegt
dementsprechend sah ich dann aber auch
nach dem lauf aus wie ein
besoffene um vier uhr nachts 10 der also
mal bilanz nach der ersten woche und
hier schon mal ein dickes schaut oder
einem schlag weil obwohl ich echt viel
gelaufen bin und mein körper richtig
zerstört habe habe ich vom laufen keine
blasen bekommen hast dumm klingt aber
das wird einen beim laufen halt komplett
ablenken die gym stocken die ich ja in
meinem letzten fitness video schon so
gefeiert haben jetzt ein bisschen dumm
aber die bequemsten socken die ich
jemals getragen habe genau davon gibt's
nämlich auch eine spezielle version fürs
laufen wo hinten noch mal extra schützen
des stoffes und die bilanz der harten
zahlen was das laufen geht kann sich
auch sehen lassen da habe ich nämlich
innerhalb der ersten woche von 2,6 auf
5,5 kilometer geschafft und mich fast
verdoppelt wenn das so weitergeht sollte
in woche 3 locker die zehn kilometer
marke drin sein
aber hier von linearem wachstum
auszugehen ist glaube ich ein bisschen
nein aber ganz ehrlich fünf kilometer
sind schon richtig krank finde ich und
die sechs kilometer
die aber auch bald aber ist das
überhaupt schlaue jeden tag zu
trainieren und sich immer 100 prozent zu
verausgaben nein profis empfehlen für
die vorbereitung auf einen 42 kilometer
marathon zum beispiel zwei- bis dreimal
die woche durchschnittlich nur fünf
kilometer zu laufen und einmal pro woche
zwischen 8 und 20 kilometer übrigens mit
ihr auch die richtige ernährung eine
riesenrolle hier werden vollkornprodukte
obst und gemüse sowie viel wasser
empfohlen ich persönlich habe ich für
den restlichen monaten keinen genauen
trainings oder ernährungsplan gehalten
sondern ging aber so oft wie möglich ist
gerade im reingepasst hat in den
stressigen arbeitsalltag aus dem
täglichen sorgen dass ich mir ja mal
voll genommen hatte wurde auf jeden fall
nichts ernährt habe ich mich wie davor
auch schon halbwegs gesund aber nicht
streng also eigentlich keine
fertigprodukte kaum fast food und wo es
gerade nur geht eigentlich vollkommen
haben hier gab es auf jeden fall einen
haufen leckere ausnahmen hier antrag 15
habe ich tatsächlich zum ersten mal beim
joggen auch mein puls gemessen der beim
laufen auf bis zu 170 gestiegen ist mein
ruhepuls hier zum vergleich ist ungefähr
bei 8 aber kann ich mit dem training mit
der ernährung und so weiter und so fort
jetzt mein ziel erreichen 10.000 meter
ununterbrochener dauer spulen wir in der
zeit doch einfach mal ganz schnell nach
vorne heute versuche ich das ganze zehn
kilometer ich bin auch nie annähernd so
weit jetzt gelaufen der gesamte letzte
monat sollte ich jetzt quasi auf diesen
einen lauf vorbereiten
deswegen ich jetzt auch noch mal zwei
stunden mit ford losgeht wollen nicht
kohlenhydrate bisschen hielt er aber
hauptsächlich ordentlich kohlenhydrate
auflade bin ich ja gleich energie haben
guten appetit
ich drehe jetzt auch sehr regelmäßig
alle paar minuten immer ein glas wasser
einfach damit ich das gleich losgeht
perfekte drehte
apropos wasser ist gerade auch ganz
schön übel
ich schaue die ganze zeit aufs
regenradar aber es wird einfach nicht
besser ist glaub ich glaube ich muss der
wahrheit ins auge blicken wir müssen
einfach beim konsum machen kilos co ja
wir sind jetzt hier da wo es jetzt
losgeht ich fühle mich gerade wie so ein
journalist sehr gerade bei reißenden
strömen berichtet nein ich muss jetzt
endlich trocken gehen und der
regenschirm hat der wird jetzt gekommen
das mikrofon auch weil wir sonst
[Musik]
ok zu tun aber ich bin ja nicht mit
einzige der toten wird also sollte ich
ziehe da noch durch ist das geil nicht
mehr zulaufen
das zucker so gut also mein atem habe
ich auch schon wieder irgendwie ich kann
aber noch mal reden aber meine beine
sind so wackelpudding mein gott meine
beine zehn kilometer das hat sich so
landet absurd jetzt war süßes zu trinken
ich bin einfach nur happy
ich habe aber aufgeben können ich habe
nicht fazit ja also den regenschirm hier
habe ich auf jeden fall nie wieder
gesehen aber es war wie ich dachte echt
sehr sehr sehr häufig um genau zu sein
den ganzen anderthalb stunden in denen
ich gerannt bin dass ich es nicht packen
wird ich war so kurz davor aufzugeben
einfach weiß extrem geregnet hat und ich
war auch felsenfest davon überzeugt dass
ich der einzige sein werde der daher
rennen wird dann bin ich da im park und
sehe einfach wie gefühl liegt da gerade
bei dem wetter jobs gibt also keine
ausreden nicht mal hochwasser erregender
regenfälle in köln und das regenwasser
war dann am ende natürlich sogar ein
vorteil weil mir relativ warm war und
nicht mehr meine füße einfach schön in
die pfützen packen konnte um mich
abzukühlen das hat echt super geholfen
meinen schuhen hat es vielleicht nicht
so gut geholfen aber mir schon ich habe
jetzt nicht die beste zeit aber hey ich
bin zehn kilometer am stück gehen ohne
irgendwie pause oder so ein brand ich
dann tatsächlich auch junge du macht
werbung für jim clark kann es jetzt
nicht einfach bringt ist das nicht meine
füße
das wird muskelkater das kann ich euch
mal sprechen aber jetzt danach ich fühle
mich eigentlich voll gut ich bin richtig
ruhig ich bin aus gelassen ich bin müde
aber ich fühle mich von entspannt
nochmal dickes dankeschön einen
tiefschlag die mir fassen
ganzen kleiderschrank an
trainingsklamotten gewonnen den link zum
shop gibt es in der video beschreibung
ich finde dort alles von t shirts bis
zwölf über tanktops und lang sowie
kurzen wurden bis hin zu diesem leisten
hätten das alles gibt natürlich für
herren und damen und am 22 sogar eine
ganz neue kollektion heraus speziell für
läufer also haltet er unbedingt mal eure
augen offen und packt auf jeden fall ein
paar paare sorgten mit in den warenkorb
wenn euch das video gefallen hat
abonniert gerne diesen kanal ich kann es
immer noch richtig krass was wir
geschafft haben fast jede woche kommen
so ein video wie das online also
verpasst das nicht ohne ansehen und
zunächst mal wieder nach zu
[Musik]